taking training to the next level a
private security company in Las Vegas is
the first in the nation to implement a
virtual reality system and a story
you'll see only here on 8 news now
Victoria Saha takes a closer look at how
this new tool is helping train officers
[Music]
Caldwell is responding to a report of a
dumpster
diversary it's a situation he's no
stranger to while working with security
company protective Force International
you don't know how the scenario is going
to play out just like in the real world
and it's the uncertainty that's put to
the test using vertra
a virtual reality system that until now
was used only to train law enforcement
and Military
so it definitely gives you that
opportunity to like think about it but
at the same time you have to still know
how to react quick enough to de-escalate
that situation we have these blue
weapons that notates that it's a
training weapon we have a Glock 17
firearm not only does this virtual
reality system help these officers
prepare for a real life scenario it also
helps with firearms training ready
foreign
this training saves the officers a trip
to the gun range and also helps them get
familiar with the tools they have in a
safer environment we're able to take the
stress level of an officer who is vet
like years of being a security officer
or just new into the industry and
provide them with real world scenario
training Jonathan Alvarez CEO protective
years process
but it was necessary our goal is to
never take those Extreme Measures we
want to answer every single call
obviously with the most minimal amount
of force possible and obviously
de-escalate that situation verbally
training for the most simplest calls to
the most intense like an active shooter
you have that opportunity to make those
mistakes you have the opportunity to
learn from those mistakes Victoria Saha
eight news now